this really has to be seen to be
believed and i believe
you will believe it momentarily i told
you yesterday how republicans and donald
trump are now
very aggressively demanding credit for
the coronavirus vaccines
which they said we didn't really need to
end the pandemic
and that the pandemic wasn't really
serious anyway
and which many of them are refusing to
take that vaccine
is the one they now want credit for well
there's now
layer two of this which is that there
are now
many republican lawmakers who voted
against the recent 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted stimulus bill that was recently
passed by
democrats exclusively and democrats
alone who want to take credit for it
republicans who want to take credit for
it let's look at some examples here
is republican congresswoman maria
salazar
tweeting over the weekend quote so proud
to announce
that the biden administration has just
implemented
my bipartisan covid relief bill
as part of small business small business
administration policy
she voted against it she didn't vote for
it
and now she wants credit for it and
there are so many of these republican
senator from mississippi
roger wicker did the exact same thing
tweeting how glad he is that quote
independent restaurant operators have
won
28 billion dollars worth of targeted
relief
he's cheering that quote this funding
will ensure
small businesses can survive the
pandemic
by helping to adapt their operations
and keep their employees on the payroll
but he voted against the bill
and now he wants credit for it and he's
bragging about it and apparently he's
going to campaign on this
republican congressman adam kinzinger
tweeted that quote
we owe it to the american people
to work together in doing everything we
can
to get them the coveted relief they need
bipartisanship is critical
in effective legislating except he voted
against it and there was no
bipartisanship despite
significant republican support for the
coveted relief bill
and then in a statement that adam
kinzinger
links to he actually says today
i'm glad to know my constituents will be
receiving an additional relief payment
and funding to help improve their access
to vaccines
ppe and unemployment insurance but he
voted against it and in the statement he
adds
but the legislation passed today
is one of the largest expenditures in
american history
with spending unrelated to the coveted
19 pandemic and republicans were left
out of all
negotiations now it's untrue that
republicans were left out of all
negotiations we've already talked about
this bullet point that's floating around
saying
91 of the money wasn't for covet
wasn't actually coveted relief well that
depends on how you define it and much of
it is for
infrastructure affected by coronavirus
public transit
affected by coronavirus when people
aren't writing public transit
coronav public transit uh infrastructure
deteriorates
and then we come out of the pandemic
with even
even crappier for lack of a better term
uh public transit infrastructure which
the us already doesn't do particularly
well in so
we did all this debunking already
but still he wants credit even though he
voted against it
radical extremist q anon congresswoman
lauren beaubert defiantly tweeting that
hell yes you should be getting the money
why
it's your money after all that you
already paid into the government in
taxes
saying quote the framing of stimulus
checks
is all wrong this is not fourteen
hundred dollars being given to you by
your generous government
this is money that you and your fellow
countrymen already paid into the system
so
if she thinks it's taxpayer money
that should go back to taxpayers why did
she vote against the money going back to
taxpayers
how can republicans who voted against
the bill
take credit for the bill and sadly part
of the answer is
if their own constituents are ignorant
enough to fall for it
and it appears that many are i mean
after all they're the same people that
voted for donald trump
if they're if they're dumb enough to
fall for it why not go with it
and thus these republicans are setting
themselves up
to when it's convenient say i refused
the pork
of the coveted stimulus but talking out
of the other side of their mouths
they can also say i am so glad
that the congress i was a part of
delivered money to my constituents
they're gonna try to play both sides
and um in a way it's kind of
simpler for us that they all voted
against it and what i mean by that is
like if some republicans had voted for
the coveted relief bill
um we would have to say okay let's see
rand paul
is trying to take credit for the bill we
have to check did rand vote for it or
did rand vote against it
they all voted against it every single
one of them so
if they have an r next to their name
between now and 2022
you know they voted against the bill and
uh we can save ourselves the time of
having to actually look it up
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read or use it to preview a book
before you buy the full version and read
it i recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great stephen
hawking this is a book that i have been
aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video